welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and the fate of Wanda maximoff
remains a mystery since Multiverse of
Madness but Thor living Thunder just
gave her a way out only it's through
hell Elizabeth Olsen for her part
remains in the dark they don't tell me
anything about my fate I I like I want
like fans to be like so aggressive you
know and like terrify them into doing it
or something I think that's not a good
way to do anything actually no I really
think that yeah fear not a good way to
do anything tell that to the Scarlet
Witch and she's being reasonable Shield
is down
love and thunder redefines afterlives in
the MCU in this new rule reframes two
major details I just discovered that no
one is talking about one in love and
thunder and one Multiverse of Madness
that make me think that Wanda may have
been like the heroines of other Sam
Raimi stories dragged to hell so
Valhalla is the Norse afterlife where as
guardian Warriors go when they die and
where Heimdall and Jane now are it is
the inverse of hell h-e-l where we saw
hella in Ragnarok and where Loki thought
he was pruned to but in fact the English
word of Hell two L's actually comes from
the old Norse of Hell one hell even
though the Norse didn't really have a
punishment afterlife like hell they just
called it hell because that's where
hella lived the Christian concept of
Hell really comes from New Testament
references to the Greek Hades and the
Hebrew sheol all of that later colored
in by medieval translations and sermons
and art and literature like Dante's
Inferno so Jane and Heimdall bean and
Valhalla now implies many Dead
characters in the MCU might live on in
afterlife Realms like this one and since
we know all of this is linked and based
on our real world religions why not add
hell to that you know the hot one Moon
Knight explored how these afterlives are
rooted in real world religion and
towerette confirmed on that series that
the duot was linked with the wakandan
ancestral plane and now we're seeing how
the gods of omnipotent City and love and
thunder include Aztec Mayan Maori
Egyptian and I believe a cited a segment
the feeling companion to Bost both of
these what kind of deities mentioned by
t'challa and also among these Valkyrie
name dropped an off-screen God of
carpentry which had to be a nod to Jesus
of Nazareth Carpenter by trade famous
for getting crucified on his era's
version of Groot now Christianity is
obviously a thing in the MC you we see
churches all the time and that includes
the darker side of that religion like
French churches in 1549 depicting demons
in stained glass and The Witches of
Salem persecuted in 1693 for worshiping
Satan yes hell is real in the MCU and
before you say I'm about to go Mephisto
confirmed on you uh hell yeah I am
ration of us is unsabbatical honey
because when I rewatched love and
thunder recently there is totally a
moment that is so easy to miss I missed
it when I first watched it in omnipotent
cities golden chamber Zeus opens by
asking where they're gonna hold this
year's orgy and then he says now we're
going to announce the winner of the most
human soul sacrificed in the name of a
God and then we got to Valkyrie and Jane
and Thor talking over him plotting to
swipe the Thunderbolts but in the
background you can hear Zeus announcing
the winner Satan listen to the audio
yourself
Jane you go right or you go left holy
[ __ ] now I will admit I have been known
to hear Devils where there are none and
there is a Greek mythological figure
named Phaeton but I definitely heard
Russell Crowe say an S there and I just
think it makes the most sense for taika
to make a joke about Satan winning the
most human Souls sacrificed right also
we saw concept art where they originally
planned to make Russell Crowe Satan I
think this joke was a holdover from that
so yeah along with a god of carpentry I
think the MCU now has a Satan with tons
of people sacrificing souls in his name
and yeah I know it's not the deliberate
hellmouth catwalk that we expected but I
feel okay saying it do this don't
confirmed in between this and mutants
what a w week for M's whether or not you
buy this as a capital M Mephisto there
is no denying hell is real in the MCU
Multiverse Madness showed us two
universes one a fiery world of Bones
another more Rocky landscape of lava
rivers that America nearly banished
wanted to before changing her mind and
realizing that hell is really a movie
night with your kids but to be clear I
don't think those two universes were the
hell I think hell is really a realm
between universes that all universes can
connect to and throughout the MCU of
course there have been pejorative uses
of the word hell like when Christine
uses the Brazier bomb galliad go back to
hell
also in love and thunder the girl loved
snaps at Thor go to hell demon but
really I think hell is actually where
the souls of the Damned come from those
Souls perhaps the ones sacrificed in
Satan's name referenced in love and
thunder these Souls Christian
equivalents to the Damned Souls that
turn into sand in the duat and Moon
Knight the inky Darkness between the
various universes is that the souls of
the Damned drag strange down into for a
brief moment that I believe is hell and
I think these Souls dragged Wanda there
too our buddy Mt spotted the amazing
catch that when strange harnesses The
Souls of the Damned initially one of
those Souls Retreats into the darkness
of his eye nesting itself into Strange's
soul and perhaps being a big reason why
that third eye opened on Strange's
forehead this discovery opened my eyes
to revisit this entire sequence so in
the scene in Multiverse Madness where it
seems like Wanda dies the darkhold
temple atop Mount wundergore collapsing
on her there was a releasing of a
Scarlet colored burst of energy and of
course there are many ways we can read
that maybe one to just igniting all of
the dark hold books in every universe or
maybe want to just exploding into energy
upon her death but I don't think so
because like strange Wanda was swarmed
by these Souls of the damn and just like
strange we see them float into the
darkness of her eye but a huge detail
here wind strange bursts threw the souls
off of him in order to form them into a
cloak when you count them there are
exactly 13 Souls now there were
originally more of them but Christine
banished a few of them and of course
there was that one that stayed nested
inside of Strange's Soul so these 13
Souls of the Damned are the ones as
strange unleashes on Wando when he
floats over the temple these Souls
surround Wanda and then Wong in cases
Wanda and the souls in a Magic Shield at
this point we see them go into her eye
but moments later when Wanda breaks free
I counted and there are now only 11
Souls so two Souls stayed inside Wanda
the way one Soul stayed in strange those
two damn Souls may be why Wanda looks so
especially evil to her 838 Sons there
was a Darkness now around her eyes that
could be why she snapped stab at and why
the goodness still in her allowed this
body to expire that red burst of energy
might have been Wanda leaving this realm
and entering another one the realm of
her dark passengers hell Dragon Wanda
down to meet their Master Two Souls that
she follows hell maybe under a false
promise that they can be her sons when
in reality they are pieces of mephisto's
soul soul sacrificed under Satan's name
now claimed by him and that 80s West
Coast Avengers storyline I couldn't shut
off about during one division finally
now getting its do like the other Realms
the MCU has established the mirror
Dimension the nor Dimension the quantum
realm the astral plane the shadow realm
I believe Valhalla The ancestral plane
and hell are all around us they can
always be accessed or they can access us
through specific waypoints another word
for that a hell mouth and when we see
Wanda next maybe an upcoming MCU titles
like blade most credits into that or in
Agatha House of Harkness maybe even in
her own solo title announced a d23 Wanda
is gonna crawl out of some horrifying
hellmouth in one hell of an entrance you
can follow me on Instagram and Twitter
at avos follow new Rockstar subscribe to
new Rockstar some more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]